It's kind of unimaginable
not believing in them.
My grandmother had
an elf friend in a rock.
The elves come to me in my dreams.
I'm convinced elves do exist.
I'm professor of Folkloristics
at the University of Iceland.
One of the areas of research
that I've been working on
is so-called 'elves' or 'álfar',
along with 'huldufólk',
'the hidden ones',
that Icelanders are so interested in.
I can picture some kind
of idea of a hidden person,
kind of looks like a human.
They have a little bit
old-fashioned clothing.
They have their own society here,
emotions and feelings.
They are born, grow old, and die.
I think they live in rocks.
They can show themselves
if they choose to, but rarely do.
But you never know
when it will happen.
You have maybe 10%
say that they don’t believe,
and then those that do believe
is again about 10%.
But in between you have all of the
rest, who are 'maybe', 'possibly',
'probably', 'who knows'.
INTERVIEWER: So if I asked
you then if you think literally
that they exist?
We can't say no.
Yeah, you can't say no.
They will come haunt us.
It's not that they believe,
they are worried that there
might be something there
when it comes down to it,
that you're not going to mess with.
My name is Pétur Matthíasson
and I'm Head of Communication with
the Icelandic Road Administration.
So this is the rock that we moved,
from the place where the road is,
and we moved it over here.
People thought that this
might be an elf church,
and these people asked us
if we could maybe move the rock.
We will look into it. Not because
we believe so much in elves
at the Road Administration,
we look at is as part
of our cultural inheritance.
We know that people in the Viking
times were buried in mounds
which showed above the earth.
As each generation goes by,
the living memory of the people
within the ground,
turns into a much more hazy idea,
about beings that live out of sight.
The nature of Iceland makes
you feel really strong emotions.
A nation where your house can be
destroyed by something you can't see.
We naturally try to explain
these things by means of
personifying the environment.
And everyone is surrounded by nature,
you see the mountains,
you see the ocean, everywhere.
The belief started because of this
strong connection that we still have.
I think there is a pressure
from the society as a whole,
that we are the people
who believe in elves
and we should tell everybody that.
Because we have been trying
to get more tourists for a long time.
I think a lot of people
will say they believe in elves,
but in heart, they don't.
If we couldn't have moved it,
we would have smashed it down.
It's just a rock.
Whether you believe it or not,
these stories about the elves
and these creatures,
they teach us to respect nature.
And the elves here are,
for the most part I think, respected.
Should the law consider
the huldufólk?
Maybe not, but I think maybe
the law should try to consider
what rights the nature can have,
because it doesn't
really have a voice.
Even though it's quite outdated,
maybe the huldufólk
is giving nature a voice.
There are people coming
from countries
who've in a sense lost this
connection, this magic.
In Iceland you can talk about
the elves and these other worlds
to everybody and people
will not lock you up.
It makes Iceland different
and they like being different
to other nations, in all ways.
We want it to be like this.
It would be a nicer place to live
if there were hidden people there.
Don 't you think?
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)